I have an important client today I'm
very excited to really understand this
client and probably impress her so I
understand you have a dream house that
you would like me to design for you so
when I met Anthea it's a student or she
didn't really talk much probably she's
trying to assess the situation how I can
handle her building you have a
connection every four levels I want my
dream helps to have a money pool and I
can see my mother maybe I want a teacher
also now I want a chef to cook something
like that you know okay
very often when clients has a lease of
extra vegan space show requests most
likely they won a very literally
translated but I always look at as
architects we as designers we always
want to look into something more
innovative a reinterpretation so who
else is living in this building
[Music]
community but she doesn't like pizza
he's my younger brother dogs so I guess
the cats and dogs have to be away from
your mother's to do right so enter why
don't you tell me a little bit more
about yourself I also have a very
special cookie one thing is quite
securely
[Music]
so you're the money pulls away anybody
and it is our duty as designers to
convince the client a reinterpretation
of what they want probably is a better
option and what I foresee is a problem
will be then be everybody are living in
silo there's no interaction so let's say
we break it down and then instead of a
horizontal plate just one data right we
break it into several data items that
came from one place you can cross in a
place to cross another place I saw her
eyes this quiet excitement so I think
she's very eager to get her hands on
[Music]
give me a few more weeks and I'll get
back to you before model okay I believe
we have met the clients expectations I
think it's not pretty bad because you'll
understand I was among the clients
coming it's going to be the first time
we've met her in person because I think
this is what the client wants what we're
looking at here is the basic for the
model on the top we've got the four
different rooms we thought the best
place is here simply because it's got
the best views first we have to come
quick the model of the house in okay
think through how she actually used the
space why she needs those spaces and how
those spaces actually interact with each
other and hence we actually came up with
something that variables if all these
floor slabs and highly customizable this
foundation we actually solve also has a
basement for a money vault there were a
lot of spaces which we haven't
encountered before so there we had a lot
of questions in our head we're done out
there I'm crossing my fingers as she
will really love it
hi auntie ah how you welcome back so
look at what we prepared for you today
we have done that physical model so that
we can better visualize what you're
talking about
so remember this is the money water you
keep talking about so there are
different layers of water money whatever
money he will understand I was I know
when I saw the money what I was very
happy that there was the money what this
roads are representative of the
structure the house cannot just be free
floating everywhere do you want your
mother to be near to your brother's room
or further away by the way cause she's
scared of that the animals are your
brother loves anyone remember so why do
we live your mother's room as high as
possible to be a little bit further away
but yes still have a visual link to your
brother what about your own room you
weren't here somewhere blossom would
there be sticker and then we just need
bullet it but it was quite fun to pick
up the kids
this was better than expected empty
about your body upon 10 not liked it a
lot
only 10 11 a Fontana glad and he loves
it
of course she take away really
understanding where we come from that we
have added value to this process
here's a low level and I also came using
to put my money I drove in I think if
you could join I'm impressed
[Music]